all right my story is British computing  pioneer and legendary world war two code  breaker Alan Turing will be the new face  on Britain's 50 pound note which is  worth about sixty-two dollars this is  this is very significance Turing cracked  help led a team that cracked the Nazis  Enigma code and in World War two which  really turned the course of the war he  did it by designing a computer that  essentially was a it was a machine that  was a forerunner of them the modern  computer but what became tragic was he  was prosecuted in the 50s for  homosexuality which was then illegal and  he died a couple years later at the age  of 41 queen elizabeth ultimately  pardoned him posthumously he was played  by Benedict Cumberbatch in the movie the  imitation game yep but he is so finally  he gets an honour that he deserves for  all that he's done for the world in fact  he was chosen from among 227,000  nominees Alan Turing well deserved